we went and by we I mean all of us we
went and built this wonderful internet
thing you've heard of and we're all
using it all the time for all of our
lives we're buying everything it we're
have we're having sex over it we're
communicating with our friends just so
many aspects of our life we're all going
on this network and we've spent immense
amounts of money to build it and build
handheld devices and the computers all
the software but what has the government
done and what has big business done
they've turned it into the world's
greatest surveillance apparatus the
surveillance apparatus that even George
Orwell probably wouldn't have dreamed of
and that wasn't why we built it we
didn't make it to be a surveillance
apparatus but unfortunately we've
learned thanks to Edward Snowden who has
revealed what the NSA has been doing
that the NSA and other spy agencies
around the world are doing this they're
making it a surveillance apparatus
they're tracking all of the phone calls
you make in terms of the records and
where you were and who you talk to and
in many cases recording the actual voice
they are because they say they need to
find a needle in a haystack
looking at the entire haystack they're
looking at everything innocent people do
in order to find guilty people and
nobody thinks that we shouldn't have
police and intelligence agents whose job
it is to find bad guys and stop bad guys
that's that's not a question but a free
society makes a decision for itself it
makes a decision to limit the power of
its police and it's intelligence agents
it makes a decision to let some bad
things happen to let some guilty people
get away in order to avoid punishing
innocent people doing surveillance on
people who are innocent and there's no
reason to suspect them but unfortunately
that's not what happens and
unfortunately mr. Snowden has shown us
just the depth to which it's going on
and that's the biggest challenge we're
facing how to make society's realize
that we do need our privacy and we do
need to limit the power of these
organizations we do need to draw a line
somewhere and more than draw a line we
need to make people think there's not
necessarily some trade-off between
privacy and security but it's possible
sometimes to keep your rights and gain
security at the same time it's just
harder the easy thing to do is just make
everyone give up their rights so that's
one of the biggest challenges going
forward now we also have challenges in
free speech
we're seeing more and more countries
around the world trying to censor their
Internet's trying to censor what people
do
getting as Extreme as Hosni Mubarak
shutting off the internet when a
revolution was coming and you know you
may think oh well that's Egypt but in
fact just before that President Obama
had asked for an ability to have a kill
switch for the internet now not of
course during a revolution he said you
know if we're being attacked or
something and we need to shut it off we
would like to have that so we're seeing
people as well self-censor disturbingly
because of the Snowden revelations we're
seeing the press afraid of what might
happen to them if they report these
stories and starting to censor
themselves and that's affecting free
speech we're also seeing a big effort
for people to take control of our
computers and have them do things that
we necessarily don't want them to do all
in the service of protecting a movie
when you download it so that you can't
easily copy it to someone else which has
never worked has never actually stopped
people from copying movies but we have a
lot of forces pushing for laws and
technology to basically lock down your
computer so not so that you can trust it
but so that movie studios and
governments and so on can trust that you
can't do things on it and that is
something that computer engineers all
know is never going to work and it's
just going to make things broken